[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen Katja Stresow ist auch dabei
für den Sport guten Abend schauen wir
auf den Nachrichtenthemen von heute
[Musik]
geschlossen und entschlossen zum
Abschluss ihres Treffens in Japan senden
die G7 Staaten deutliche Signale an
Russland und China
Richtungsentscheidung in Griechenland
erste Zahlen zur Parlamentswahl gleich
in dieser Sendung
und Pflicht sie gegen Ungarn das
deutsche Eishockey-Team bleibt auf Kurs
WM-Viertelfinale
[Musik]
der g7-gipfel in Japan ist zu Ende
mehrere Hilfsorganisationen kritisieren
dass die sieben Industrienationen nur 21
Milliarden Dollar für humanitäre Krisen
bereitstellen nach Angaben der UN
braucht es mehr als doppelt so viel als
Erfolg des Gipfels gilt die gemeinsame
Haltung gegenüber China und Russland und
die uneingeschränkte Solidarität mit der
Ukraine aus Hiroshima berichtet ultra
Land ist bedroht von russischen
Atomwaffen nun gedenkt er im
Friedenspark der atombombenopfer von
Hiroshima die G7 Staaten wollen ihn
unterstützen solange wie nötig
Präsident beiden hatte sich vorher der
Kampfjet Koalition angeschlossen
silensky hat dafür lange gekämpft und
beiden verspricht noch mehr
ich verkünde heute weitere Militärhilfen
die beinhalten Munition Artillerie und
Panzerfahrzeuge
die Groll Taten des Krieges verfolgen
selenski wo immer er ist ein Reporter
fragt ist bachmut gefallen
ich glaube nicht da ist aber auch nichts
mehr die Russen haben alles zerstört es
gibt keine Häuser mehr es ist eine
Tragödie bartmut gibt es nur noch in
unseren Herzen
hat auf dem Gipfel die G7 und ihre
Partner getroffen einige wie der
indische regierungschef-modi Vorurteilen
nicht den russischen Angriffskrieg der
Bundeskanzler will um ihre Unterstützung
werben sagte im ZDF das kann uns gut
gelingen wenn wir jetzt spätestens
anfangen auf Augenhöhe miteinander zu
sprechen dafür habe ich schon beworben
bei dem g7-gipfel den wir in Deutschland
ausgerichtet haben und das ist sehr sehr
wertgeschätzt worden
die Ruinen des atomdoms sagte selensky
später erinnerten ihn an die Zerstörung
in bachmut heute sei Hiroshima eine
schöne Stadt das gebe ihm Hoffnung
Hiroshima welches Signal geht von diesem
Gipfel aus
vor allem die Botschaft an China
bildlich gesprochen eine geballte
entschlossene Faust die sich aber ganz
schnell auch in einer ausgestreckte Hand
verwandeln könnte die G7 sind absolut
geschlossen was die Unterstützung der
Ukraine angeht gleichzeitig wollen sie
gegen jeden Vorgehen der es wagt den
Angriffskrieg von Putin durch seine
Hilfe zu verlängern und das gilt auch
für China unabhängig davon welche
wirtschaftlichen Abhängigkeiten es gibt
sie lenskys reisemarathon dass er so
einen unternimmt dass er mit Ländern wie
Indien redet die skeptisch sind und dass
er eben auch immer wieder
Friedensinitiativen gut findet das
unterscheidet ihn von Wladimir Putin der
im Bunker setzt den Moskau und keine
Rede Bereitschaft zeigt und das so hofft
man hier ist vielleicht auch ein Signal
nach Peking dass man doch Druck ausüben
könnte auf Putin um einen Frieden zu
vermitteln das ist auch ein Signal hier
die groß die G7 wollen im Grunde
genommen die Hand ausstrecken sie würden
sich freuen wenn man dieses ganz viele
andere Probleme gemeinsam mit China löst
statt in einen echten Konflikt zu gehen
Dankeschön nach Hiroshima immer die
wissen war das
der Bundeskanzler ist nach dem Gipfel
nach Südkorea weitergereist zuvor sagte
er das heizungsgesetz sei auf einem
guten Weg große Planänderungen werde es
nicht geben das sieht die FDP ganz
anders sie will das ganze verschieben
und überarbeiten und die grüne
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Göring-Eckardt
fordert mehr Unterstützung auch von
Scholz wenn die hescher hat Details hier
irgendwo zwischen den Stühlen und
Fraktionen hängt der Gesetzentwurf fest
auf den die Bundesregierung sich im
April verständigt hatte hier im
Parlament muss er beraten werden aber
hinter den Kulissen wird so heftig
gestritten dass ich hier die Frage
bereit macht kommt das heizungsgesetz
noch ich glaube allerdings dass es nicht
dazu kommt dass jetzt im Kern große
Veränderung vorgenommen werden aber es
ist natürlich völlig in Ordnung zu
gucken sind alle Fragen beantwortet sind
alle Bedenken berücksichtigt damit das
so ist dass wir die Ziele erreichen die
wir erreichen wollen wenn wir Klima
zentral Wirtschaften wollen in
Deutschland aber das ist gleichzeitig
niemanden überfordert zum Zeitplan sagt
der Kanzler nichts in seiner
Ampelkoalition ist es die FDP die nach
Zustimmung am Kabinettstisch nun auf der
Bremse steht das Gesetz müsse im Kern
überdacht werden ein großer Teil der
deutschen Bevölkerung macht sich Sorgen
über die aktuelle Version des Gebäude
Energiegesetz laut Umfragen sagen 75%
der Menschen dass dieses Gesetz so nicht
kommen kann deswegen ist ganz klar es
bedarf grundsätzlicher Veränderung wir
brauchen auch keine weitere Ausrede auch
keine Verzögerungstaktik warum die
Menschen brauchen jetzt Sicherheit die
müssen wissen was kommt müssen sich
darauf einstellen können und auch es
mussten Ende der Verunsicherung geben
viele Leute haben ja das Gefühl was
passiert mir da eigentlich die Ampel
steigert sich zunehmend in den
heizungsstreit hinein ohne die
Streitpunkte konkret zu benennen was die
Verwirrung für Mieter und Eigentümer nur
vergrößert
das ganze Interview mit dem
Bundeskanzler können Sie in Berlin
direkt sehen direkt nach uns in
Griechenland waren heute rund 10
Millionen Wahlberechtigte aufgerufen
über ein neues Parlament abzustimmen
darunter viele erst Fehler bisher
regiert die konservative Partei mehr
Demokratie unter
regierungs-tages mit absoluter Mehrheit
herausgefordert wird sie von Ex
Ministerpräsident Zebras und seiner
links gerichteten Partei sirisa fragen
wir nach in Athen bei Andreas Postel wie
sehen die ersten Prognosen aus
die Wahllokale sind hier vor einer
Stunde geschlossen und es liegt eine
aktuelle Prognose vor dem nach hat
amtszen aber
das Wahlergebnis von vor vier Jahren
bestätigt er liegt damit aktuell bei 36
bis 40 Prozent der Stimmen und kann
damit als der eindeutige Wahlsieger
bezeichnet werden er ist allerdings
Sieger ohne Triumph denn nach dem
aktuellen Wahlrecht das hier herrschte
kann er die absolute Mehrheit nicht
erreichen sein Herausforderer von der
Linken siri-partei Alexis cipras ist
ebenfalls nicht in der Lage einer
Regierung zu bilden er liegt damit jetzt
bei den aktuellen Zahlen um 25 bis 29%
der Stimmen und ist auch sehr viele
Koalitionspartner angewiesen um einen
Regierungswechsel herbeizuführen also
entweder jemand koaliert mit den
Drittplatzierten der Linken der
Sozialdemokratischen passag Partei die
etwa 9% der Stimme erreichen oder aber
es gibt Neuwahlen Amt aber keine Jacke
mit zur Tages jedenfalls hat heute hier
von den Griechen offenbar das Vertrauen
ausgesprochen bekommen das ist jetzt nur
eine Prognose Hochrechnungen kommen dann
im Laufe des Abends aber soweit hier mal
ein erster Stimmungstest aus
Griechenland danke schön Andreas
in El Salvador hat es bei einem
Fußballspiel eine Massenpanik gegeben
mindestens zwölf Menschen starben im
Gedränge und 100 wurden mit teils
schweren Verletzungen in Krankenhäusern
gebracht zur Panik kam es als sich
hunderte Fans nach Anpfiff noch vor den
Stadiontoren drängten ist diese
schließlich geöffnet worden nun wird
spekuliert das zu viele Karten verkauft
wurden die Regierung kündigte Aufklärung
an
und jetzt Eishockey Katja da sind die
deutschen Nationalspieler auf Kurs WM
Viertelfinale ein bisschen Arbeit ist es
noch aber in der Tat mit einer Kuh
verstehen sie da fast schon drin nachdem
sie gegen die Außenseite aus Ungarn es
war nach eigener Aussage nicht das
schönste Spiel dieser WM den Finnland
und Lettland stattfindet aber am Ende
steht ein 7:2 Erfolg
nach einem ellbogen-check bekommt
Maximilian Schuber eine Match Strafe im
zweiten Drittel wackelt die deutsche 10
Führung auf einmal lange in Unterzahl
doch und ganz Ausgleich zählt nicht die
Partie ist vorher unterbrochen
Unterzahlspiel hervorragend gelöst hat
uns wieder in diesen Fokus
zurückgebracht und dann kam die drei
Tore ihres zweiten Drittels das erste
gleich Anfang des dritten und und somit
ja konnten wir beruhigt sage ich mal
unser Spiel durchziehen die NHL Profis
John peterer und Nico Sturm mit zwei
Treffern leiten den dritten Sieg
nacheinander ein Jonas Müller stellt den
sieben zu zwei Endstand im finnischen
Tampere her Deutschland ist jetzt
Tabellen vierter auf dem Platz fürs
Viertelfinale einen Punkt vor denen die
morgen gegen Schweden spielen letzter
Deutscher Vorrundengegner ist am
Dienstag Frankreich
im ersten Sonntag spielt der
Fußball-Bundesliga hat der VfB Stuttgart
4:1 in Mainz gewonnen dadurch sind die
Schwaben auf Tabellenplatz 15 geklettert
und haben es am letzten Spieltag wieder
selbst in der Hand den Abstieg in die
zweite Liga zu verhindern und noch zu
einem großen Erfolg für daher favolomit
bei den Europameisterschaften in Baku
Aserbaidschan holte die rhythmische
Sportgymnasien aus schmieden die
Goldmedaille mit den anderen Geräten und
der meerkampf noch ohne Fortin lief es
für die 16-jährige dieses Mal mit dem
Band entscheidend besser nach WM Gold im
vergangenen Jahr nun also ihr erster
EM-Titel
und im August ist wieder WM mit 16
Hammer dankeschön gerne die neue Woche
startet sommerlich gewittrig im Osten
und Südosten viel Sonne sonst von Westen
her aufkommende Schauer und Gewitter
Lokal Unwetter mit Starkregen und Hagel
Höchstwerte 21 bis 29 Grad und die
weiteren Aussichten wieder kühler und
zunächst noch unbeständigt das heute
journal mit Christian Sievers um viertel
vor zehn wir sagen tschüss bis morgen
die ganze 19 Uhr wünscht Ihnen einen
guten Start in die neue Woche und
empfiehlt jetzt
Berlin direkt und mit dem Kanzlerin
vielen Dank Barbara ja Olaf Scholz gibt
selten Interviews aber heute konnten wir
Ihnen sprechen was er zu den großen
Krisen der Weltpolitik sagt zu Kampfjets
im ukrainekrieg und zum Koalitionskrach
über die wärmewende jetzt bei uns
herzlich Willkommen bei Berlin direkt